[Applaudissements]
snif snif snif que se passe-t-il madame
l'art et moi vos déboires que vos
pensées magiques tout comme vos seins en
poire cessez donc mon ami tous vos
enfantillages et que nous en fait je
suis une femme volage
je viens ici vous dire que nos temps de
rose amour devient est obsolète
pas plus je te jure commandons mais
madame d'où vient ce revirement alors qu
à l'instant même vous fûtes au firmament
je le sais mon aimée comme le semo vagin
encore tout récent temps de votre fonds
longera de ces assauts viril de sa
gourmandise mais mais mais mais femme
d'un seul homme
tel doit être ma devise certes après que
vous mutine ultime fois binet mais ma
chère qu'advient-il de nos folles virées
tous ces moments intimes que je suis
fâché garder les en mémoire
il vous émoustilleront chaque fois que
votre nouilles tapera votre ceinture ans
mais ne vous méprenez pas sur cette
courte algarade je n'oublierai jamais
nos folles incartade
tous ces moments intimes a frotté
marmotte qui sont autant d'extase visa
votre carottes vraiment ma bien aimée
jeu je ne comprends toujours pas ce qui
change notre idylle mon amour tout cas
qu'à ces temps-ci mon amour je dois m'en
retourner auprès de mon mari ce bon
vieil amédée qui manie bien la baisse
mais moins son pays allait tudieu je ne
saisis point encore moins que tantôt
depuis que vous y êtes d'un objet de
rando sports auxquels je m'adonne quand
l'hiver s'en vient et que les
demoiselles s'en vont voir les
bouquetins vraiment mon bien aimé vous
aimez la montagne et moi qui supputer
que c'était la campagne l'endroit où
passait le plus clair du temps en
compagnie des frères de votre maman
que nenni ma jument je déteste le purin
les chemins dégueulasse et tous ces gros
bourrin qui peuplent la cambrousse de
notre verte contrée et picole des
mousses jusqu'à son faire gerber mais
revenons en donc à notre bavardage vous
tentiez de me dire que vous changiez
d'adage et vous n'oublierez donc un
cruel 14
ici fait mon bien d'une telle est notre
destin dignité devant ce désamour
je m'en vais ridicule et moi qui rêvais
une dernière fois il ment il as
[Applaudissements]
merci merci merci bien bon en fait voilà
je m'appelle jean sébastien trudeau jeu
de rôle là pour l'instant je m'appelle
jean sébastien trudeau et comme vous
pouvez l'entendre un petit peu là je
suis québécois ce qui est bien pratique
avec notre accent c'est que ben quand on
cherche quand céline dion ou garou ou
bien quand on quand on déclame du
théâtre ou en pot n opèrent notre accent
je tiens à préciser quand même une chose
c'est que je n'ai absolument rien
n'avoir avec jean sébastien bach
on a juste le même prénom c'est tout ce
qu'on m'a déjà posé la question ce que
je voulais vous dire voilà c'est que moi
donc dans la vie vous avez compris ce
comédien plus exactement comme on dit
chez vous chômeur fusil exactement comme
comme comédien je suis humoriste une
mort est là avec un seul est humoriste
chez maurice tu alors là vous vous dites
là en fait moi mon truc c'est les
sketches ce que j'aime c'est un carnet
créer et incarner des personnages jouer
des rôles est ma grande passion dans la
vie en fait c'est même pas du tout ça
effectivement j'adore le théâtre j'adore
jouer mais comme l'a dit steffi je suis
journaliste scientifique
allez c'est chiant
mais ce que j'adore ma passion vraiment
c'est la scène n'adhère pas le cours
d'eau non j'adore monter sur scène et
rire rire et faire rire donner et
recevoir
et quand les gens rigolent moi ça me
rend heureux et en fait je ne sais pas
peut-être que vous ne vous êtes jamais
posé la question mais on joue tous des
rôles dans la vie dans la vie du
quotidien
on joue tous des rôles différents par
exemple je sais pas au travail on joue
un rôle en famille on joue un rôle avec
les a mis au jour encore un autre rôle
quand on est dans les transports en
commun on joue encore un autre rôle
différent par exemple tout bêtement vous
êtes dans le bus avec votre petit gamin
j'étais dans le bus avec mon fils ça
faisait cinq minutes comme ça qui fixait
une vieille dame
puis tout à coup il se retourne vers toi
fais pas pas très loin comme ça papa
pourquoi elle est moche la vieille dame
mais enfin c'est non non excusez le il a
deux ans enfin on dit pas ça enfin ça va
pas didon excusé le oui ben voilà on dit
ça est en réalité quelles sont nos
devrait dire qu'on devrait qu'est ce
qu'on a en tête
oui tu as raison elle est moche la
vieille dame mais en plus elle est
grosse et elle put on le dit pas
socialement c'est pas acceptable ce nom
pareil vous êtes au boulot boulot ça
fait trois mois que vous bossez sur le
dossier machin ayez votre patron qui
déboule la veille de la présentation il
vient vous voir l'effectif
je le sens pas là on va tout reprendre
depuis le début et puis ces prêts demain
9 heures qu'est ce qu'on a envie de lui
dire à son patron à ce moment-là eux
j'enfile un bar l'a dit tu déconnes nous
quoi attend ça fait trois mois que je
bosse nuit et jour sur ce truc et tu
viens l'avait il me dire qu'un en fait
ça le fait pas non les 10 passes à son
boss qu'est ce qu'on lui dit cheppi
chauffard non excusez ma quand vous
dites on reprend tout à zéro c'est genre
on peut quand même reprendre
non on peut pas reprendre des bouts de
lancer un truc voilà on est comme ça on
joue un rôle dernier des derniers
exemples en date barack obama avec
donald trump
oui je suis sûr que ce sera un bon
président 1 et mon équipe et moi même
allons tout faire pour que la passation
de pouvoir se passe dans de très bonnes
conditions
en réalité baraque à ce moment là ils
pensent quoi bon de cons mais on est
foutu voilà tout ça pour vous dire que
voilà dans la vie de tous les jours on
en douce plusieurs et ce qui est le plus
important en fait dans notre vie c'est
d'être l'acteur sa propre en être
l'acteur n'est pas simplement un
figurant une doublure et encore moins un
spectateur être vraiment le rôle
principal c'est ce que cherchent à
comédien acteur dans la boue c'est la
consécration du soir reconnu ces deux
recherches
c'est le rôle
m